[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGGIE STANPHILL: Good
morning, everyone.
Welcome to the last
day of I/O. Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
We're really excited
to be here today,
because this is the
first time UX writing
has been on stage at I/O,
so thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm Maggie Stanphill, and I
manage a team of UX writers
at Google, and we work
on travel, shopping,
and payments products.
And I'm joined here today by
members of my team, Allison
Rung and Juliana Appenrodt.
And today, you're probably here
for the same reason we are.
We're passionate about building
products that people love,
and we're here to share
an insight with you that
will keep users coming
back again and again.
It's choosing the right
words, because we all
know what can happen when
you choose the wrong words.
Take, for example, the first
time you use a social app.
Can you imagine if
it said, "No friends.
How sad?"
It'd be a pretty bad
start to a new friendship.
So what we're here to
share with you today
are insights to make sure you
can apply content strategy
to your product.
So over the next
35 minutes, I'll
share an overview of
content strategy of Google,
Allison will share three
UX writing best practices,
and Juliana will
share a case study
about how we defined brand
voice for Android Pay.
So let's get started
with how we approach
content strategy at Google.
Many of you know that we follow
principle, focus on the user,
and all else will follow.
But what you might
not realize is
that for us, focusing on a
user starts with the content.
The content is the text, the
reviews data, the imagery.
This is content strategy--
the holistic development
and crafting of content
in the product experience.
And UX writing is a specialty
within this discipline
that focuses on
helping users achieve
their goals with language.
And in my five years
here at Google,
I've had the great
opportunity to work
on a number of
products, and I wanted
to share a few
scenarios with you,
so you can get an understanding
of how we approach our craft.
So for this example, let's
say a user is searching
for an Italian wine
store in San Francisco,
and they're looking for
the closest one to them.
The label, Sort
by Distance, helps
them find the right location.
This has been the product
of a ton of research
and a lot of
iterations to ensure
we're surfacing the right
information at the right time.
Another example is when
we're helping a user write
a review on Google Maps.
We offer information,
such as the fact that this
will be posted publicly,
to engender trust,
and we offer a helpful prompt--
"Tell others why you
like this place."
So hopefully, it's a quick
way to get them started.
Just curious, how many
of you have written
a review on Google Maps?
Show of hands.
Awesome.
Thank you, guys, so much for
contributing to the community.
All right, and this
time, I'm going
to take you into the
kitchen for some hands
free help, and with
using only their voice,
a user can get directions for
their recipe on Google Home.
So what all three of these
have in common is language.
Language is helping the user
get where they want to go,
and by focusing on what
the user wants to achieve,
this builds trust and loyalty.
This is what content
strategy is all about.
So at Google, I wanted to
share a little bit about how
we structure our team.
We've made a big investment
in content strategy
as part of our user
experience discipline.
Content strategy is part of
an overarching group that
focuses on the user
experience and focuses
on building holistic
product solutions,
partnering with a
cross-disciplinary team
of writers, researchers,
and designers.
Writers work with
designers to think
about information
hierarchy on the page
and to guide user actions.
Writers work with researchers to
test hypotheses about language
and inform our insights
with their great research
capabilities.
We found that this
holistic approach
to solving these complex
user product problems really
helps us create better
user experiences.
But what might not
be quite as evident
is the impact that
this focus on language
can have on the business.
So I want to share
with you an example
from Hotel Search on Google.
This is a great example, where
literally changing two words
had a significant
impact on the business.
We used to have a label
which read, Book a Room,
and what we found was this was
far too committal at that stage
in the decision-making process.
So we switched it to,
Check Availability,
and what we found was this
was meeting the user where
they were at in their mindset.
They were still
considering rooms,
and they wanted to understand
what dates were available, what
prices were in that date range.
And so with those two
words, Check Availability,
we saw a 17% increase
in engagement.
That's a significant
impact on the business.
Sometimes the other end of the
spectrum is harder to measure,
but equally important--
that emotional connection that
users have with a product.
Sometimes we call this emotional
connection brand voice,
and I want to share a
little bit about how
you might approach defining
brand voice for your app
or product.
So first, start
with the benefits.
Really consider how to
enunciate the most standout
traits of your product,
and then consider
how your product's
differentiated
from its competitors.
When I had the opportunity to
work on the Google brand voice,
we took our lead from
the Google search page.
Its simplicity and ease
of use was a cue for us
to inform our brand voice
tenet around usefulness.
We also took our lead from
the delightful Google Doodle,
and we have a tenet,
which is around optimism.
And you'll hear more of
this throughout the day.
So basically, we have
this brand foundation
with our brand
voice, and it applies
to our suite of products.
And I'll share with
you a recent example
that I had the opportunity to
work on with my team, which
is the Google Trips app.
And if you guys
haven't checked it out,
I highly recommend that you do.
It's a fun app in
that it helps you
organize all of your
travel information,
so it's available offline.
So you can download
reservations,
and if you arrive
somewhere without data,
you can still access it.
So when we were thinking
about the benefit,
we landed on a line,
which reads, "No internet.
No problem."
Paired with a
delightful illustration,
we think this really tells
the story of both the benefits
and the excitement of travel.
So through our experience
here at Google,
we found that when you have
the foundation of UX writing,
and you add brand voice, we
know if some of the parts
come together, something
really amazing can happen.
We believe that UX
writing can certainly
survive with the
fundamentals, but it
can thrive with brand voice.
With that, I'm going
to hand it over
to Allison, who will talk
about our three UX writing
best practices.
[APPLAUSE]
ALLISON RUNG: Thanks, Maggie.
My name's Allison
rung, and I'm a writer
on the Trust and Privacy team.
Part of my job is to explain
why you see ads on Google
and to show how you can control
those ads to make them better
for you.
Like any other
writer at Google, I
learn a lot of
technical language
before translating
it into something
that anybody can understand.
The technical language
that I start with
tends to do with
advertising and ad networks,
but this challenge is common
for any product writing.
How do you translate what's
happening on your back end
to the other side of the screen?
How do you make your
software sound human?
This work is pretty
intuitive for writers.
We think about the technical
context we learned about,
and then we think
about the person who's
using the app or the product.
And then we decide
what sounds right.
We tend to say
what we're writing
out loud to make sure that each
word has the right ring to it.
But I know many of you don't
have writers on your product
teams yet, so today I'm going
to try to reverse engineer
this natural writing
process and guide you
through three of the
principles that guide it.
These are principles that
we've kind of internalized,
and they are clear,
concise, and useful.
I'll start with clear.
So let's say that somebody is
trying to sign in to your app,
and then they mess up their
password for whatever reason.
And then they see this--
"Error-- Failure.
An authentication
error has occurred."
This sounds terrible, right?
Right.
It reminds me of
those restart messages
we got on our first computers in
like the late '80s, early '90s.
Remember those?
There was a bomb that
was about to explode.
It said something
about system error.
What was going on there
and what's happening here
is a disaster in software
terms, because the function
can't be completed.
But for people,
it's not a big deal,
and we can tone down
this language a little.
So in other words,
failure and authentication
are software problems,
not human problems.
And we can improve them by
switching them out to something
that people can relate
to like signing in.
"Sign-in error-- a sign-in
error has occurred."
This is better, and notice here
how a single term, sign-in, has
replaced two different
technical terms, failure
and authentication.
So that should tell you that
clear doesn't mean precise.
It means just enough
context to make sense
to your typical user.
And I know a lot of you
work on enterprise apps,
or you're writing
for specialists.
Specialist language
is totally OK
when you have a
specialist audience.
You just have to keep
your own audience in mind.
All right, so another way you
can make your writing clearer
is to pay attention to verbs.
A verb is an action word.
It tends to be the most
powerful part of your sentence,
and ideally, it will relate
some action to the user.
Here our verb is, has
occurred, and it's a weak verb,
because it's describing a state
of being within the software.
So to make it better,
we'll just switch it
for what the user is
doing, the user's action.
"You entered an
incorrect password."
Pretty simple, right?
OK, so this is clarity.
With clarity, we
remove technical terms,
and we put the action in
the context of the user.
This is an especially
good lesson
to remember when you're writing
your product announcements
or your app updates.
Instead of focusing on the
technical specs of whatever
new feature you're releasing,
try to focus on the new action
that people can perform.
The second principle is concise.
Concise doesn't only mean short.
It means something
closer to economical,
so when we're writing
with concision,
we look at our
message, and we make
sure that every word on the
screen has a distinct job.
Here, the header doesn't
have a distinct job.
We don't need it.
The body is working
fine without it,
and this is a very common
problem in product writing.
We have a ton of superfluous
headers or subtexts or sidebars
or descriptions, because their
design shows some preexisting
text field, and then you
feel compelled to fill it in.
But you should really
avoid that when
you can, and instead,
practice content first design.
Content first design
will make sure
that your visuals are
working in service
of what you're trying to say
and not the other way around.
So try not to jam your
messages into boxes
that weren't meant for them.
And ideally, try
to have designers
work in parallel with writers.
OK, so now we've gotten
rid of our header,
and I've been adamant about
removing extra text here,
because as you all
know from experience,
we don't read every
word on screens, do we?
We scan.
So this is a mocked up heat map
from an iTracking study showing
where people's
focal points land.
We know that people's eyes
follow an F shaped pattern
as they read screens.
They read the first line,
maybe the second line,
but then they start
skipping down the page,
catching only the first or
second word of each sentence.
So for this reason, we keep our
text not only concise, but also
frontloaded.
Frontloading means to put
your important concepts first,
so people's eyes catch
those important words
as they skip down.
Here, we're in trouble, because
the most important concept,
the incorrect password,
is all the way at the end.
And we can fix it by
flipping this around--
wrong password.
So now that we've done
this, it turns out
we don't need
anything else, right?
This is fine.
These two words are
working on their own.
You won't always be able to
reduce your text to just two
words, but this principle
will always hold true,
and you can use
it anywhere where
you're writing for screens.
Keep the most important
text up front,
and then ruthlessly edit
whatever comes after it.
All right.
Now we're onto our
final principle, useful.
You want your text
to help people
to get where they want to go.
And now we'll talk about
the only part of the message
we haven't looked at yet--
the call to action, or CTA.
Calls to action-- they
tend to be button text,
or they're hyperlinked,
and they guide people
to their next step.
So for that reason,
they need to resonate
with what they want to do.
Here, OK is not a good
CTA, because people
aren't generally happy or
OK with the wrong password.
No, they want to
try again, right?
So Try Again is a
perfectly good edit.
But if everyone
here, if you think
for a minute about all the
hundreds or thousands of times
you've messed up your password--
I know for me, it's usually
on airline websites--
you'll realize this
isn't all we need, right?
Right.
Good.
Yeah, it's early
here in California,
but I see people nodding.
Yeah, we need to offer
password recovery, too.
If you forget your password,
and your only option
is to try again,
you'll only be annoyed.
OK.
So I know you guys
are all pros, and I
know that you have this basic
sign-in behavior covered.
It's a very common pattern.
But what I want
you your take away
is that paying attention
to writing and the people
you're writing for can uncover
some of the basic functions
your app needs to offer.
So if you don't think of those
edge cases and write to them,
then you might see some
drop-off in your usage.
OK, wrapping up, clear,
concise, and useful--
if you pay attention to
these three principles,
you'll connect better
with your users.
But you may have realized as I
walked you through this editing
exercise that good UX
writing is not a science.
There's no correct answer.
These three principles
aren't in perfect harmony.
There is a kind of
tension in between them.
They're competing
with each other.
When we made our text clear,
it was still pretty long.
It wasn't very scannable.
Then when we made the text
concise, it got shorter,
but that was at the
expense of some clarity.
And then finally, when
we made the text useful,
it stretched out.
It got longer again.
It became less scannable.
So you can find
the right balance
between these principles.
When you think about
your user's context,
think about what she
wants to do in the moment.
And you can also look toward
your product's brand voice.
Your brand voice
should guide you
to the right balance between
clear, concise, and useful
in a way that's true to
your product's character.
And you can begin to find the
elements of that character
by thinking about the
core function of what
your product does,
and then think
about what makes it special,
how it's differentiated.
As Maggie mentioned,
Google's brand voice
is designed in part
after our search page.
Search is an
everyday tool, so we
like to use everyday,
friendly language.
And search is also
pretty clever,
so we use clever
language sometimes,
but we're not too
clever, because we want
to be accessible to anyone.
Our language also
reflects the optimism
of search that you can
see here in the I'm
Feeling Lucky button or
those Doodle illustrations
that Maggie mentioned.
I like to talk through
Google's brand voice
with this old slogan
from Google Earth.
Hello, Earth.
This is so simple, right?
This is positive
and forward-looking,
and it's inclusive to the point
of welcoming the entire globe.
There's also a
slight play on words
here, where Earth refers
both to the product
name and the planet.
And we all know
this Android slogan.
This sounds Googly, right?
Be together, not the same.
Many of us love this,
but why do we love it?
Why does it sound so Googly?
How is it working?
Well, first of all, there
is this overarching theme
of inclusion that we saw
on the Hello Earth slogan.
And there's also a
play on words here,
which reflects the
optimism of our brand.
Be together, not the same.
As we read this, there's
kind of cognitive surprise.
We read, "Be together, not,"
and we expect something
like the opposite
of together, apart.
Be together, not apart, right?
But Google replaces,
apart, with, the same.
So now we get across the
concept of difference
and even celebrate it
without any negativity.
Be together, not the same.
So again, we're a
very positive brand.
Coming back to
this drab password
message, wrong password,
this is great UX writing.
It's clear.
It's concise.
It's useful.
It would work for any product.
But if this came across the
desk of any of my writing
colleagues, I think they would
update it to be more on brand,
and they'd probably change
it to something like,
"That password
doesn't look right."
And they would do that,
because since optimism
is so important to
our brand, we don't
like to lead with negative
words like, wrong.
We're also OK with making
the text a little longer,
a little less concise in order
to be friendly and chatty.
That password
doesn't look right.
So now this sounds like Google,
and it's right for Google.
But that doesn't mean
it's right for your brand.
So it's up to you to figure
out what the right sound is
for your own brand voice.
So to help you with
that, you'll hear
from Juliana, who will
talk about building
brand voice for a new product.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIANA APPENRODT:
Thanks, Allison.
Hi, I'm Juliana Appenrodt, and
I'm a UX writer on the Payments
team.
One of the apps I work
on is Android Pay.
Some of you might
be familiar with it.
You can use it to pay
with your Android phone
in stores and in apps.
A few months after we launched
Android Pay, a team at Google
conducted some research around
the app's brand strategy.
And what they found was that
the brand characteristics
we were initially
emphasizing, things
like simplicity and security,
were things that people just
expected of a payment method.
They weren't differentiators.
This pushed our team to
think a little bit more
about what the Android Pay
brand should look like.
And for me, when
thinking about what
words should go in
the user interface,
this meant going beyond the
basic UX writing principles.
If we really wanted to
connect with our target users
and get more than
just the most tech
savvy to adopt this
new way of paying,
we needed to give Android
Pay a unique brand voice.
Now Maggie and Allison
both talked a little bit
about the Google brand
voice, and since Android Pay
is a Google product,
we definitely
wanted to stay
true to that voice.
But there are many
Google products,
and each one serves
a different purpose
in people's lives, which means
that each product's voice can
and should sound a
little different.
Android Pay is also
distinct from some
of the other more
established Google products,
because mobile
payment apps are still
seen as a thing of the future,
especially here in the US.
And research showed that
we had an opportunity
to appeal to the more emotional
dimensions of the Android Pay
experience like the
excitement people feel
the first time they successfully
pay with their phone.
These are the moments where
we can give Android Pay
a recognizable personality.
Here's one example of how
we've done that visually.
The Android Bot, which
is part of the app logo,
comes to life on the
payment confirmation screen
to celebrate different
holidays and events.
As you can see, he dressed up as
Darth Vader just a couple weeks
ago for May the 4th.
It takes a combination of
visuals like this and words
both working together to
bring your product's brand
voice to life.
Right now, I'm just going
to focus on the writing
side of things and walk
you through how we've
started to develop
the Android Pay voice
and how we bring that to
life through our UX writing.
The hope is that
this will give you
all a sense of how
you can start to do
the same for your products.
So it's best to start with
a set of brand principles.
These can be just three
or four adjectives
that you feel embody your
brand and represent how
you want people to perceive it.
A fun brainstorming
exercise you can
do to help you come up
with these principles is
to imagine you're signing your
product up for a dating site.
What words or info would
you put in your product's
dating profile?
What is it about
your product that you
think would stand out or be
most interesting to people?
What will make them swipe
right and want to learn more?
You can then distill
these qualities
into descriptive words,
which will become your brand
principles.
We did this exercise
with our team,
including designers,
researchers, engineers,
product managers, and marketers,
and we all got together,
and we did some brainstorming.
And based on that, as well as
the research that was done,
we ultimately defined
the Android Pay brand
as fresh, empathetic,
and approachable.
Once you have your
brand principles,
the next step is
to think about what
these principles will sound
like when you apply them
to your writing.
And these will become
your writing guidelines.
For example, to sound
fresh, we decided
we need to write in a way
that's snappy and exciting.
This principle comes
into play a lot
when we're trying to really
grab a user's attention
and really hook them.
And sometimes this can
be before they've even
started using our app.
When someone types, Android
Pay, into Google search,
one of the top results takes
them to our marketing website,
where they'll see a series
of imagery and headlines
like this.
Here, we have a chance
to really pull people
in and get them to think,
I need to try this app.
And that's where the
snappy language comes in.
Headlines like, "Tap.
Pay.
Splash," and, "Tap.
Tasty," not only
highlight the tap
and pay functionality behind
Android Pay, but also the fun
things you can buy with it.
They show that how you pay can
be equally as exciting as what
you're paying for.
Empathetic-- we
know that changing
the way you do an
everyday thing like paying
can feel uncomfortable and
maybe even a little scary.
So to counteract that, we
try to write in a way that's
helpful and reassuring.
Often, this means anticipating
the questions or concerns
a user might have
and proactively
providing them with answers.
On this screen, we do just that.
First, by saying, "Enjoy
quick setup with this card,"
we're reassuring
the user that they
won't have to go
through that dreaded
process of typing in a credit
card number on their phone.
Then we explained
that we've pulled
in this card from
their Google account.
That way, they're not left
wondering where in the world
we got this information.
Through our language,
we want to show users
that we're doing
everything we can to help
make their lives easier.
Approachable-- this one
means we want everyone
to feel like they
can use Android Pay,
that it isn't just for
the most tech savvy.
To convey that
feeling in our app,
we write in a way that's
friendly and conversational.
This means eliminating the
jargon and the formalities
and simply talking to
users in the same casual,
easy to understand way
we talk to our friends.
When we're explaining to
users how Android Pay works,
for example, we don't
talk about NFC or HCE
technology, because the
average user would likely
have no idea what that means.
Instead, we talk in terms
everyone can understand.
Unlock your phone, and hold it
to the terminal at checkout.
We don't need to get into what's
going on behind the scenes.
That should give you an idea
of how brand principles can
be applied to writing, and
once you have your own brand
principles in writing
guidelines in place,
you should start to have a
pretty good sense of what
your product's voice
will sound like.
Then you can take
it a step further
and think about what
your voice will sound
like in different contexts.
This is often
referred to as tone.
An easy way to remember the
difference between voice
and tone is to think
about it like a person.
A person's voice always
stays the same, right?
But the tone they
talk to you in may
change depending
on the situation
or what they're saying.
In an app, this
might mean talking
to users in a different way
during a celebratory moment,
like when they've just
won a prize, versus when
their network
connection goes out,
and they're seeing
an error message.
For Android Pay, we mapped
these different moments
in the user journey on a tone
spectrum ranging from serious
to whimsical.
This helps us make
sure that we're
using our voice in a consistent
way across the entire user
experience.
For your product, the
two ends of the spectrum
might be labeled differently.
Your tone might range from
informative to inspiring
or direct to humorous.
These are just a
couple examples,
and you'll be able to tell
what works best for your brand.
It can also vary a lot depending
on what type of product
you're building and
who the audience is.
Once you have the two ends
of your y-axis labeled,
you then need to determine what
moments in the user journey
you're going to map.
A good way to do
this is to think
about the distinct milestones
or interactions in your user
experience.
These can be things like
onboarding, education,
or troubleshooting.
To help you decide where these
will fall on the spectrum,
you can then think about
what the user's goal is,
what they might be
feeling in that moment,
as well as what you'd
like them to feel.
To give you an
example, I'll show you
where we mapped a few of the
Android Pay user touch points.
The first impression-- when
we're making a first impression
on the user, we aim for
a very whimsical tone,
because we're
trying to get people
excited about Android Pay.
This could be when they're
seeing an ad, opening
the app for the first time,
or, as I showed you earlier,
landing on our marketing
site, where they'll
be greeted with a
whimsical headline
and a rainbow sprinkled
donut to go with it.
When the user is setting up
the app or using it to pay,
our tone still falls on the
whimsical end of the spectrum,
but to a lesser degree.
That's because in
these moments, the user
is trying to get
something done, so we
don't want our personality
to get in the way.
Error messages fall on the more
serious end of the spectrum.
When a user sees an error,
they might be frustrated,
so this isn't the right time for
too much personality or humor.
Needless to say, we're
not going to tell the user
that something's
up with their card
or to holler at their bank, if
they're having an issue adding
their credit card to the app.
Instead, we want to
be straightforward
about the issue, and
tell them how to fix it.
So we'd say, your card
couldn't be added,
and contact your bank.
All right, you've
established your voice,
and you've mapped your tone.
Now it's time to apply both of
these and do some UX writing.
It's time to decide what words
will go in your user interface,
and that ends up being a
combination of everything
we've told you today.
To be successful, UI text
needs to be clear, concise,
and useful, as well as
reflect your brand voice.
To show you how
you can get there,
I'll quickly walk you through
what our writing process might
look like.
Let's say we're trying to
decide what to say to the user
the first time they
open Android Pay.
We can guess that
they're curious,
so we probably want to tell them
what they can do with the app,
as well as give them reason
to move beyond this screen
and set it up.
At the beginning of
our writing process,
we might start with something
long and descriptive like this.
Pay with your phone in stores,
and enjoy quick checkout
in apps.
Then we think about the three
principles of good UX writing.
This text does feel clear and
useful, but it isn't concise.
So we think about what
pieces of info are essential
and which ones could
be communicated
through visuals instead.
And we might edit it to
something like this--
"A faster way to pay."
With this new
version, we've checked
off clear, concise, and useful,
so we have just one step left.
We need to think
about voice and tone.
We'd ask ourselves, does this
text clearly convey our brand?
Not really.
It feels pretty generic.
So going back to our
brand principles,
we think about how we can
make it feel fresher and more
exciting, maybe even
whimsical, since this
might be our first
impression on the user.
And in our final
iteration, we might end up
with something like this--
"Everything you need to
speed through checkout."
It's a little longer than
the previous version,
but that can happen when you
add personality to UI text,
and it's up to you whether
infusing that personality
is worth the extra words.
And it isn't always
a clear decision.
If you're not sure whether more
words will be more effective
or whether a certain word will
be more effective than another,
A/B test it.
From experience, we
can say that when
you're trying to find the
right words for your product,
you should never underestimate
the power of A/B testing.
Through an A/B test we
ran on the Start screen
in Android Pay, we discovered
that changing the button text
from "Add Card" to "Get Started"
resulted in a 12% increase
in click-throughs.
Pretty amazing.
A/B testing is a great way to
validate a hypothesis you might
have or to decide between two
different versions of text,
if you're just not sure
which one will connect more
with your users.
Now I'll hand it back to
Maggie to wrap things up
and to share a handy checklist
you can start applying
to your own UX writing.
[APPLAUSE]
MAGGIE STANPHILL: Thank you.
Thank you, Juliana.
So we've heard from Allison
about the best practices in UX
writing, heard about
brand voice just now,
and I wanted to reflect
on our first sad screen.
I think we can do better, right?
All right, let's
apply what we learned
and do a quick on-brand edit.
So a simple way to make this
much more positive and much
more useful is, "Ready
to add some friends?
Import your contacts."
So adding that simple call to
action, import your contacts,
could help the user get started
and, ultimately, have a better
relationship with this app.
So we hope what we
shared with you today
will be a helpful
reference as you get back
to work after this
great few days at I/O,
and consider how you might apply
some of these best practices
to your product.
So a quick run-through--
we recommend that you
always think about the user
first, focus on the
user, and all else
will follow is a mantra we
love to think about here.
Be clear.
Write in language
that's free of jargon
and with sufficient context.
Be concise.
Write in a style that's
economical and scannable.
Remember the F shape pattern
that Allison described.
Be useful.
Write in a way that
guides the action.
And if you don't have
a call to action,
you might want to add one.
And be on brand.
Define your brand voice, and
flex your tone accordingly,
as Juliana described.
Finally, whenever
possible, be data-driven.
If you can apply A/B testing
or other user testing,
it's a great way to test your
knowledge of your language
and how well it's
resonating with the user.
In sum, I want to, first and
foremost, thank these two
amazing contributors.
We'll be up front.
If you guys have questions,
please come up and ask them.
We hope that what we
shared with you today
will help you make your product
stand out with language.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]